so someone guy goes on the rampage
called with an empty piece of paper
added
from the young man a blank sheet of paper in
his hands
[music] the
word
dog
what
.
I have long been the
decree of the governor of the Novosibirsk
region number spencervale dated March 18,
2020, also the decree of the
governor of the Odessa region
on February 9, 2022 number.  street
events and
the solitary picketing which, as
I understand it, now interferes are prohibited if
your unlawful
actions
are not stopped, provided for in Article 20.  6.1 I demand to
immediately stop your illegal
actions they
repeat they demand to stop yours and the
huge ones
all took away
such children's police if a person
comes out even with an empty clean piece of paper a
blank sheet without any slogans
you all want proof of the
absurdity enough look at it is worth losing
this channel
he is kind